I've always hoped that it would be a big
Kim pyres you said not me Kim
kardashian-west opening up to et at
Forbes women's summit in New York on
Tuesday about her family new makeup line
and the biggest lesson she's learned as
an entrepreneur minutes before you
walked in here today
you actually tweeted about k'kaw beauty
yes we need more on that what is that
yes so I am launching my own makeup
brand we're launching with a contour kit
so it's gonna be cream contour and
highlighters in like this collection
with great brushes and I'm so excited
about gonna be so it's so exciting what
would you say so far has been your
smartest business decision I think my
smartest business decision has been
going for it and not being like having
no fear and just even if they failed and
even if it hasn't turned out the way
that I wanted to I've learned so much
from it so my advice would be go for it
everything's about learning experience
is there something like a specific
example you can think of that maybe
wasn't this morning for this decision or
something that you did they were like oh
okay they've done this differently back
in the day I used to just be involved
with so much yeah whether it was like
tanning or shoe you know I starring your
name on your dad oh yeah which I mean I
loved the process of it all but you know
being a cupcake
you know sponsored to a cupcake store I
mean like everything but put it throwing
myself into everything taught me
everything I know now so I wouldn't take
any of it back
yeah you know like we had a store in
Vegas called Kardashian Khaos fit was
like the ultimate Kardashian merch store
and that didn't work out the way that we
wanted it to
but we learned that that's just so
time-consuming and that we should just
really be extra cautious with our time
so that experience was amazing
what can you hope that north and Saint
learn from your hard work and your
success I hope that they just find their
own motivation and no matter what that
is no matter what they want to do in
life I hope that they work really hard I
think they have good example I'll earned
from seeing both of my parents work
really hard and I think our kids will
see Kanye and I work really hard and I
hope that's motivating for them and just
to find their own path they think to not
pressure but to definitely have our
rules is the best that you can do
[Music]